This is exciting, you're from Delaware.
You were just named Delaware's most famous person.
I think that's really cool.
(cheering and applauding)
That's a, that's a state.
That's right.
That's an entire state and you're the most famous
person there and plus I was thinking about it today,
that means you beat Joe Biden.
I know, I know, I honestly don't know how I did that.
He didn't even make it in the top three.
Is that true?
Yes and I was trolling him on Twitter because I was like
how did this happen?
How do, you were vice president.
Yeah.
But I, I'm just really famous there
for many things I guess.
Yeah.
Were you and who else did you beat?
I'm just curious, who else is from there?
Wow, Valerie Bertinelli, the guy...
George Thorogood.
Yeah.
Really?
Yeah, George Thorogood and the Delaware Destroyers,
that was the name of his band.
What?
Andy.
(laughing)
Okay.
All I know is he's pissed at your right now.
Yeah, yeah.
It wasn't, it was a vote, it was like an online vote,
I don't know, I didn't ask for this.
(laughing)
I heard Dr. Heimlich of the Heimlich maneuver.
Yeah Henry Heimlich, what's up, I beat you.
(laughing)
Sorry.
How many lives have you, he saved millions of lives
and you still win.
Doesn't matter.
Number one.
Yeah, you're getting real cocky about it.
First state, number one.
(laughing)
It is the first state.
That's right.
That's right, first state to ratify the constitution.
Yeah, whatever, we're number one in everything.
(laughing)
Whatever.
Were you, you, you're famous for some things that you
did there when you were first getting started out,
still living in Delaware, didn't you pull a few stunts
that people still talk about to this very day?
Yeah they had the picture of me when they announced
my number one position was of me in a duck costume
because I'm famous for going into a McDonald's
in a very dangerous neighborhood dressed as a chicken
and I had a bunch of little kids that were also dressed
in chicken costumes because we were doing
The Ugly Duckling at the community theater
and this isn't like a funny story but I just asked
the woman at the counter if I could
have a 20 piece human mcnugget.
(laughing)
And she said, we don't have that.
And I was like, well what do you have?
And she said, chicken.
And then I started screaming and like squawking
and then all the kids started squawking
and then we like ran out and ran down the street.
So this is, this is what got you in this sort
of the legend of Delaware.
I don't know but probably.
Okay.
People still talk about it to this day.
And Joe Biden never did that.
Yeah.
No.
(laughing)
He couldn't do that.
Yeah, he didn't commit to it.